نتقل الان الى هذه الكلمه لوزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجي لافروفت منها عود
نفضوا تهريبا للمخدرات
بافغانستان
تستخدم
علينا ان نفكر في انفسنا وكما ذكر فخامه
الرئيس كل هذا يطبقوه في الواقعه
نحن نعتمد او لا نعتمد او لن نعتمد على
ناروتو
ونحن ويجب علينا ان نقوم بكل و في وسعنا
لكي تكون منظومه
المستقله تعمل لصالح دوله
الى عمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وللسنوات الماضيه اخرى حيث كانت فرضت
لقوبات الشديد علينا ونحن نعرف ان طبعا
هناك عوار في تطورنا وهمم
حيث يعتمدنا بصراحه
بشكل سجي على سلك التصريحات لتسعينيات
القرن الماضي في البيت الابيض بشان ضروري
تقسيم العمل
للي اعتمادي على
المواصفات الجيده والامتيازات لكل طرف او
الذكر
للاقتصادي مواردنا ومصادر الاكتساب
النتائج الجيده والمرجو كل هذه كل هذا
الكلام فارغ
هو الحقيقه ان كما
ذكر
الرئيس
مواصلاته السياسه
الاكتساب باكثر مما اللازم
هو طبعا
هناك محاولات للحفاظ على عمله دولار كعمله
موحده
ويتم استحداثه الدولار حاليا للتريونات
لاستعمال هذا او استخدامه هذه العمله
اللي
لتحويله او لجذب كل هذه الاسواق الغذائيه
والماليه
لا يتعلقوا بالتنازلات
النوم
ولذلك هم
يحاربون رؤوس
يشطبني كامو نيبر
هذا هو بيت القصيده
الواقع
واغلبيه الدول في العالم تدرك ذلك
طبعا نحن نحتاج الى فرصه من الوقت
فرصه ثانيه
الغربيه الاقتصاديه نحن نحتاج الى الى
فسحه من الوقت
وقد اغرقنا في هذا الوحل الغربي
وانا علي يقين بانه في قريب الاجل سوف
نلاحظه
انخفاضه
انخفاضه في اداره الاقتصاد العالمي كما
يشاؤه للغرب
اشتقنا
للتفاوض
والغرب
علق جميع
الاقتصاديه الرياضيه والثقافيه ونحن نعتمد
على اولئك الذين
ماسنجر
[موسيقى]
وسائل الاعلام
نستمر في لقائنا في طائر عالي
ينقطع الصوت
اذا المشاهدين
واياكم جزءا من هذه الكلمه لوزير الخارجيه
الروسيه
التي تبعناها طبعا الجزء من الذي تابعنا
قبل قليل بان الغرب علق جميع الاتصالات مع
روسيا ومع ذلك لن نخضع على لسان هذا
الحديث وقال باننا سنتخلص من النظام
المالي همم الغربي لكن نحتاجه الى وقت
كذلك قال بان روسيا لن تقدم اي تنازلات
ردا على حديث في واشنطن قال بان البيت
الابيض يضغطوا من اجل تطبيق روسيا
واستهداف اقتصادها كذلك قال همم بان الغرب
فقد مستقيته كشريك وسنستعيد الاصول
الروسيه المسروقه كما تحدث وقال همم
الولايات المتحده ايضا همم تستخدم الاصول
مثلا الافغانيه الماليه لخدمه اغراضها
الشخصيه هذا ابرز نجاح حتى
لحظه في حديث وزير الخارجيه الروسي سر جي
لافروف واخيرا قال باننا سنقوم بكل ما
يلزم للوصول الى الاستقلاليه الكامله
لروسيا